hi everyone uh please join me in
welcoming Bernice Hermann who will be
talking about monitoring generative Ai
and large language and vision models
thank you Bernice
[Applause]
okay uh sorry for all of the technical
stuff
um great I'm really excited to talk to
you guys about monitoring in the era of
generative AI large language and vision
models and embeddings and why truly
scalable approaches matter
I am a data scientist at why Labs ml
observability company based here in
Seattle
okay so what is our agenda uh perhaps a
little sped up today but
um what we want to talk about first is
just an introduction to why labs and why
logs are open source data logging tool
um then we're going to talk quite a bit
about generative AI large language
models and embeddings
um what what are the concepts what kind
of lessons maybe have we learned as a
community and as a company who has a
number of customers using these sorts of
models what does it mean to deploy them
what does it mean to monitor them and
then we'll finish up with kind of
privacy and scale and merge ability why
these things are important particularly
for kind of modern AI sort of things
so this is a screenshot at one time of
uh y logs so y logs is an open source
Telemetry tool for machine learning data
so what did what changes machine
learning data compared to maybe other
data is when we're looking at Telemetry
for any other application we care about
a lot of the same things we want you
know availability of our surface up time
different metrics things like this but
those metrics tend to be quite simple in
the case of a machine learning
application or data science application
more broadly there's more questions that
we have that are much more complex about
the data itself so not only do I want to
know maybe log here's some data that's
coming through my application I also
want to know questions like what's the
distribution of this what are you know
what is the 99th percentile of this
particular metric what are some error
bounds on that percentile right there's
a lot more information that a data
scientist or a machine learning engineer
needs to know and why logs is an open
source tool to be able to profile data
either batch data so kind of you know
CSV file this sort of thing or streaming
data so Kafka stream these sorts of
things for that information
okay so what do we work on here at y
Labs
um so this is maybe one diagram to
describe the multiple pieces so you have
in a production environment
um and there's lots of different ways
that you may be producing uh data or
transforming that data so live inference
um data that's streaming in maybe a
real-time system API endpoint batch
inference so maybe you're you know
running a weekly job or a daily job to
for some model offline so just training
and testing of your of your data feature
stores these are some different ways
that you might see your data in your
production environment all of those data
sources can be profiled with Y logs to
create what is on this picture this kind
of orange square
a piece of AI telemetry
that Telemetry can then be passed on to
why Labs observe observability platform
to do a number of different things so
anomaly detection uh some storage of
that Telemetry debugging visualization
triggering pipelines and and different
systems and team workflows to work not
only with the data scientists you may
you know view this data in one way and
analyze this data in one way maybe a
notebook or or database but Engineers
who may have different tools as well as
business stakeholders as well right who
will have many questions about the
alerts and what's happening with our
data but may interact with it in a
different way and so we want to bring
we've built a platform to be able to
work on that same data and understand
that data together
okay so these are the two areas that I
focus on most
um as a data scientist
I think a lot about why logs are open
source tool and that's because it has a
lot of really complex statistics
um and theoretical data science or sorry
theoretical computer science backing it
up this is not my computer so I don't
know who called
um I shouldn't have accepted it but now
maybe I shouldn't have
um and the second half so outside of the
open source is the um the platform side
so all of the really interesting anomaly
detection and machine learning that we
do on your time series of data as it
comes through over time is something
that I work on as well
okay so uh these are just a couple of
features that you'll see um at y labs
and things that I've been thinking about
lately so they've made the slides so one
is performance and bias tracing so
thinking about how once we have data
about our model or our data sets they
don't have to be machine learning models
although today we'll focus on that how
we can think about the performance of
our system breaking it down
understanding it over time
um and you can see here things like
tracing dips in our performance or
changes in our performance or anomalies
that we may get if we have monitors on
this to specific subsets of our data
that are important
um
other things to think about and that you
have available in the platform are
things like feature importance and
explainability so um you may when you
train a model
decide to calculate feature importance
many different algorithms to do so but
using that feature important it's
important to have this because now this
can start to prioritize the different
features that we have in our data I mean
this is incredibly important for
production users we have customers who
have thousands of features right and
looking through those manually
understanding those manually is not a
thing that's very feasible so being able
to calculate things like feature
importance and track that and do things
like sort and monitor based off of that
importance is helpful
um and finally something that I work on
a lot is how do you analyze embeddings
um so for those of you have who have
worked with embeddings we'll actually
talk about embeddings in a little bit
but here's a picture on the left of
imminist um in kind of two-dimensional
PCA space
um and you can see the so for mnis there
are hand-drawn digits zero through nine
and you can see dots representing
different digits in this two-dimensional
space
um often if you're working if you're a
data scientist and you're working with
embeddings what you'll do often is look
at a chart like this maybe it's with PCA
maybe it's t Snee or umap but we're
looking at these sorts of charts to
understand well how is this clustered
um how how is this clustered how do we
like where are the different errors and
issues that we have in our data set well
in production that's extremely difficult
especially just with volumes of data
many many clusters and things like this
so we had to think about new ways to
analyze embeddings data Beyond just the
TC plot right and I won't get a chance
to talk about this in this presentation
in too in depth but I'll say that um
we've come up with some really
interesting approaches about creating
references within your embedding space
to understand the distribution of
distances or or cosine similarity
between incoming data and
clusters and definitely and kind of
representations of our embedding space
over time and you can compare that now
to our training data to see is there
some Drift from our training data or day
to day batch to batch to see if there's
some changes in the types of embeddings
that are being sent to your system
okay so now let's move on to generative
Ai and large language and vision models
uh so uh these are just some articles
right of uh many many kind of references
and attention to um these generative
models and foundational models by not
only just you know tech companies and
organizations and researchers but also
the general public
um I don't know I'm sure many of you
have this as well my parents and friends
are constantly asking me about this all
of the time and I'm like I don't work
there but you know I'm sure we've all
fielded those sorts of conversations so
it just is a testament to how popular it
is in general public
and this means that companies as well
and researchers have really started to
think about how do they apply these to
you know their work their organizations
um so I want to just go through a couple
of definitions I don't think that any of
these terms that I'm using have a single
definition I mean I think that's just
the nature of kind of how we live our
lives now but I'm going to give some
definitions and some kind of Concepts so
that we can be on the same page for the
rest of the presentation
so for generative AI the definition that
I'm going to propose is like any
software program that uses statistics to
produce a realistic output that contains
entity or structure that is not
previously defined so very interesting
uh definition maybe not clear so I want
to give some examples that may help us
to understand it so if I asked what
computer vision is I think we can start
to start the structure of how we will
Define these and I will think of a
machine learning model or any model
really or Software System that takes in
an input and and passes out an output so
for computer vision you might say just
generally that computer vision is the
set of models or tasks where you pass in
an image and you output anything
something it might be an entity so some
sort of classification it might be
regression it may be object detection it
may be words
natural language processing similar but
the input is text the output is many
many different possibilities
okay now we'll switch to classification
where the input could be many different
things
um it could be an image it can be text
it can be tabular data of many different
types graphs all sorts of things but the
outputs are classes
um and the important thing to think here
are that these classes are predefined so
maybe their definitions from wordnet or
somewhere else but these are predefined
classes maybe within your business as
well
okay regression so these also could have
you know a variable number of inputs but
the outputs are numerical often like a
kind of a univariate number right a
single number
that describes this input in some way
predicts something so maybe it's you
know a price or anything like this
okay so now we come back to generative
Ai and our definition that we had before
and I think the easiest way to fit this
into this framework would be to say that
generative AI also has a flexible number
of in types of inputs
um and the output is very complex maybe
it's like this text or image
seemingly realistic that's typically
what we use for the term AI although AI
is a term is very vague and not not one
of my favorites but um it's it's complex
it's realistic and more importantly it's
not comprised of previously defined
entities or structures right so there's
some structure that may happen when I
you know create my architecture for a
model it may be clear that this is going
to be text that is formed or images that
are formed maybe even the size of those
are set but there are no kind of
entities or building blocks that were
already defined for this that's not to
say that there can the features that are
engineered by hand although that's not
typical these days with generative AI we
tend to have very large like neural
networks okay so hopefully that is
enough to get us on the same page for
generative AI
now let's talk about large language and
or computer vision models the definition
I will use are language or computer
vision models we saw those earlier built
on very large often millions or billions
of data points I'm often with similarly
large millions or billions of parameters
if especially if this is a neural
network
um so we see here this is actually a
multimodal
um Transformer so it doesn't look huge
here but but uh there's that in in this
picture is doing a lot of work so there
are many many many many steps and
parameters involved in building this
neural network
um and in this case the there are many
different top possible outputs using
these different task heads and the size
of data sets for computer vision and
natural language processing is exploding
so here's a really cool set of charts of
Trends in training data set sizes I mean
you can see the scale as we get kind of
past 2020 we have things like 12 digits
in our in our size of data points
okay so finally our final definition for
today what are embeddings
so the definition that I'll use are
multi-dimensional vectors of numerical
values to represent some entity
um and the cool thing about embeddings
is often they have meaningful geometric
relationships although that's not
required to be an embedding
okay so here's some examples maybe we
have three objects like bicycle banana
and car and they could be just the
concepts themselves they could be
entities maybe they're um I don't know
within our organization we may have some
entity for bicycle banana and car they
may be just strings the actual words
themselves they may be documents or
images of these things but in all of
those cases we will represent them as an
embedding with some Vector of numbers so
just for Simplicity here these are three
dimensional vectors we have a sparse
embedding this is something that often
have so in this case it's a one hot in
vetting basically we have a one in one
column and then zeros in the rest of the
columns and so this is helpful these are
still used in models especially for
tabular data for categorical information
um but there's some things that are
missing so banana and bicycle I actually
none of these are really related but
bicycle and car are related right
they're vehicles but if we see in our
spice sparse embeddings uh they're
they're no more similar than banana and
bicycle or banana and car right um so
this is what dense embeddings um often
give us is that um when we're able to
not just use kind of all zeros with one
non-zero input we can now use
um some Flex Flex numbers like some real
number and these often have nice
relationships within between each other
so you might see that bicycle and car
are closer together so we have values
like five and seven and five and seven
for these two while banana is a little
bit more distant
and of course often we have many many
more Dimensions than the two or three
that we see here
okay
and so
then we get to kind of create what's
called an embedding space so these are a
number of terms related to machine
learning that I kind of grab some
embeddings for and plotted and you'll
see some relationships between those
terms they are all pretty related so
maybe maybe less clear relationship than
we would like to see but if we had other
terms you'll certainly see these grouped
together
okay so now let's move on to deploying
and monitoring generative Ai and large
language and vision models
okay
um so how does an organization
um update their large language and
vision models for specific tasks I mean
maybe it updates the wrong word here
only one or two of these options are
update but I'm going to
I'm just into kind of four different
options
um one option if you are hoping to
utilize a large language or Vision model
or generative model of any sort is to
use a pre-trained model as is right so
there are many vendors and and Cloud
providers who have pre-trained models
that you can access for you know very
cheap individually maybe expensive for
you know certain applications and you
don't really have to train a model or do
anything especially if these are you
know generic enough and your task is
generic enough so I may you know get an
API get access to some company's model
and you allow my customers or use my
customers data to run using that model
to let's say answer questions in your q
a page or something like this these
models are built on you know a very very
large corporates of general purpose
images and texts drawn from the internet
often and so because it's General you
can get away sometimes without
fine-tuning or retraining
the second one here so to the top um to
the right is fine tuning the task head
only so this is the case
um when we talk about transfer learning
and fine tuning this is kind of the
original thing that we've done and that
is to take the model and keep all of the
weights from most of the model and
replace only the kind of tail end of
this so the task head or the cross
entropy layer at the end things like
this so what this means is that I'm
trusting the model weights of this model
I just maybe want to predict something
different at the end maybe maybe I have
a model that I don't know predicts an
imagenet class and instead I want a
model that predicts something else
related to my business I would just find
my in my labels of something else and
retrain that last layer that translation
and this this works pretty well because
the other layers of the model have
learned a lot of semantic information
that's helpful to us
okay so now the third one
um fine-tuning the whole model so this
is uh utilizing the pre-trained model
but we don't freeze as many
um or maybe any of the model layers
um and so we're at least using those
weights at the beginning uh this is
super important so it is incredibly
expensive to train these models by hand
and gets more expensive as we continue
down this list but by fine-tuning a
model starting with a basis that is
pre-trained it means that all of that
work to move toward convergence or just
move out of kind of the random
initialization phase has been done
beforehand for us we're just training on
top of that and allowing those weights
to move as we train with our specialized
data
um and so an example to give is
something like using a general language
model for like legal text in that case
you would consider perhaps fine-tuning
the whole model starting with a basis of
General text is fine but we may want to
build on top of that finally full model
training right so this is saying oh
maybe I'll take an architecture or you
know customize an architecture and train
a model from scratch this is incredibly
expensive it takes months and sometimes
well many months to train these very
large models and
up to millions of dollars is actually
quite crazy these days
um but it's something that you can do so
it makes the list
um these are just four pictures to maybe
remind you of these so pre-trained model
as is we're locking all of the weights
across the whole model fine tuning we're
just taking that last layer and we're
tuning that layer but locking the rest
fine-tuning a whole model where we're
unlocking all of the layers starting
with an existing model but changing
and uh for a full model retrain we're
initializing the weights randomly and
starting from there
okay
um what do you need to monitor in those
scenarios so this is what we've thought
a lot about at ylabs and continue to
work on and through for different
applications so for uh um actually I'll
start I'll do the reverse this time so
let's start with the full model
retraining
um if I'm retraining the model with my
specific training data then the data
that I need to use and understand is
actually specific to my use case which
is really nice because it's unlikely
that you have the billions of data
points that like lie on in some of these
large data sets have I'm so it might be
a little more feasible although it is
quite still expensive and large if
you're trying to train such a complex
model
um moving to the third one so
fine-tuning the whole model this is
helpful because we are fine tuning on an
existing model
we need to specifically think about our
training data our specific training data
for fine-tuning the task head
we we want to monitor our specific
training data but we need to understand
drift of the model so this is kind of
the the key part here is that as we use
models that have been trained by people
outside of us
um what we need to understand that model
and understand the workings of our model
in production is actually that data
because if we think about data drift if
we think about anticipating issues in
our in our system and in our model often
what we're doing is we're comparing the
data that we had the data that we train
our model with to the data that we're
seeing in production for this day right
and so when we are retraining our model
using our own data then we have that
model that the or the data that the
model was trained on but as we move
closer and closer to pre-trained models
we need to start understanding that
pre-train that data used for free
training
um which we don't often have right many
of these models are proprietary
so
um it's helpful to have that specific
training data for the the task head
fine-tuning
um but really you're missing that drift
this understanding of well how does this
new data differ from the data that the
model was trained on so I can understand
where this model may go wrong
um without the full understanding of the
underlying data and distribution of it
and that is especially true when you use
a pre-trained model as is you certainly
will do some testing with your own
specific data data that you anticipate
people to use but you will really need
to understand the distribution of data
that the model was trained on so that
you can monitor for differences between
the two
okay so I'm going to go quickly through
this section I just we had some time
issues so again things that we've
learned from this generative AI boom
Transformer model architecture is going
strong
huge data sets are kind of here to stay
or continuing to to grow
um this is from a paper actually here at
the University of Washington where I
also work
um changes in training data set are the
key to understanding the effective
robustness of your model so the
effective robustness is kind of the
difference between how well your model
works on either your training data or
even in held out test set from the same
distribution
to how does that compare to how does it
actually work with new data from other
users right and so if that difference is
effective robustness it turns out that
scaling your model is great better model
architectures can help a little but the
actual makeup of your data set and
changes in your data set are the the big
key that they found for for explaining
this robustness of models
um and then the one that I want to talk
about most user Behavior with AI systems
is evolving so users
having used maybe chat GPT and seeing
these more and more on the market they
use your models differently they use
your tools and websites differently so
what this means is that anticipating
what sort of things that someone might
type into let's say like a q a bot or
something like this that is much harder
to do and that makes the study of drift
and monitoring that much more important
okay
um how am I on time just
two members cool
um why monitoring needs to nail privacy
scalability and merge ability for modern
AI so production data is huge just just
as the data sets that we use to train
these models is huge um production data
is often voluminous Dynamic and maybe
even streaming like this picture here
and so many practitioners try like
simple sampling techniques you may split
up the data and based on time or other
things to conduct analysis
we think a lot about that at ylabs and
then I want to talk about our approach
to privacy mergability and scalability
so our approach to privacy is profiling
this raw data locally and only capturing
the meta features and metadata or only
sharing that over the cloud
um so the the benefits of this is
twofold in the world of modern AI with
these very large data sets and models so
one is as we do our monitoring and
things like this we don't want to
analyze our full data set every time
that includes billions of rows of data
and so what we want to do instead is
capture information and statistics about
this data
so that we can a use it in services like
y labs to monitor over time but B to
describe these data sets right like how
helpful is it to have something like the
lion 5 billion data set captured in a
very small file size description of the
data and of the distribution of data so
that you can compare your model and
monitor your your income incoming
traffic to that that's just impossible
in a case where we're trying to use the
data in its raw form
um I'll skip that
um scalability so being able to do this
effectively for huge amounts of data is
important here are some statistics on
how the speed of being able to measure
this so four seconds for 1.2 million
rows and so on and so on
um and then lastly data merge ability is
important so this idea I won't go into
it much today but this idea of I can
capture information about our data set
but in today's world with very large
data sets they're often comprised of
many data sets and we need to be able to
intelligently combine those together and
describe them together and this is the
concept of data mergeability I mean it's
something that we focus on very heavily
for y logs are open source
and it enables just a number of
different
um kind of tools and metrics that we
wouldn't have before error bounds
overlaps relative information
distribution drifts it's powered by data
sketches and a number of algorithms that
we're starting to build on top of that
it's lightweight configurable mergeable
streaming and statistically sound often
comes with error bounds as well
um and together we can build tools and
best practices for monitoring data in a
way that scales to production especially
as we kind of enter this world of
generative Ai and large models
um please go check out ylabs um to to
kind of see some of the other
functionality behind beyond the open
source and thank you I don't know if I
have time for questions but I'll just
say that you can reach me at Bernice
ylabs.ai
Bernice on most social media and please
do come pick up some swag in person or
if you miss it you can fill out a form
to get some slack later
and that's it thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much for news I think we
have time for one or maybe two questions
uh anybody from the audience
well
one question that I had is thinking
about like the reproducibility of large
language models is that part of the
platform at all and thinking about that
like you know when you ask a question
the the answer might change when you ask
it the next day yeah yeah so right like
uh so these systems are
non-deterministic right like so you can
give in an answer and it may give a
different answer
um it's a really really interesting one
to think about um especially as people
who use or build on top of those systems
um one because that is even more
explanation of why we need to store data
related to different points in the
system I don't know if you guys remember
for chat GPT but um chat GPT was trained
until some date in 2021 I forget what
what date maybe October maybe
um who knows what month but um and then
people ask questions that happened after
2021 and there were answers and everyone
was like what is going on you've lied to
us it's been trained until this date
right so these sorts of things are very
important if you're building a system on
top of this I mean why you have to think
about your monitoring in a kind of
profiling of the data sort of way
because it's not enough to you know
recall the model and get information
because those that information may
change
yeah thank you so so much another answer
for Applause
everything
[Applause]